today I would like to talk about
electrical conductivity so we're going
to try and measure the electrical
conductivity of this little aluminium
ring so to measure the electrical
conductivity we've got a really big
electrical conductivity measuring device
which sees how far we can fling it
so this is a big metal coil which could
draw a hundred amps if we if we could
let it and so what we do is we switch
this on it will prove a massive current
going round it as the current builds up
this will produce a magnetic field and
this magnetic field will send currents
going around this disc the currents
going around this disc will make another
magnetic field which will oppose the two
of them and then just like when you
stick two bar magnets together they'll
fling apart and so this should go
shooting down the lab and we'll see how
far it shoots and that will tell us how
well it's conducting so I'm just
plugging in and checking that I've not
done anything wrong good so so when we
flip the switch it will go bang it's
gone I've gone here we go right so went
as far as the gloves right so next we're
going to see if we can make this fly
further try and get it much more
conducting so we get a bigger current I
have to replace the fuse each time
because this wants to draw a hundred
amps these fuses blow at 13 amps and we
use the fuses to stop the whole thing
setting on fire not the fastest
reloading cannon course not the most
powerful one either so so the plan now
is to try and increase the conductivity
so if you cool something down you'll get
more conducting so here we've got a duo
of liquid nitrogen we dip that down into
here sir
boiling away then if you can see it
boiling away right this should go a bit
further so this is on this is ready
that's steaming and boom
right so down the lab don't run in a lab
we managed to hit the back of the wall
oh that's cold
oh so it went the whole way to the back
of the lab first time we shot it it went
from the cannon one desk to desk to the
glove we've gone one two three four five
and a bit whole way into the wall so
that's moved over twice as far
so the piece of metal is made of lots of
different atoms so the atoms are
arranged in a lattice which is nice and
periodic but when it's at room
temperature which is quite hot it's
moving around all the time there's lots
of vibrations going through so it's
shaking around all over the place the
two are vibrating towards each other and
when it's nice and cool this is
vibrating much less so the current that
we're trying to put through it is made
of lots of electrons and electrons can
move through the lattice if it's nice
and periodic because of quantum
mechanics they're ways they like to move
through things which are nicely arranged
but if you've got the atoms vibrating
and moving towards each other it's
suddenly not periodic anymore
it comes across the sound wave the atoms
vibrating will come in and they'll knock
it off so what you really want when you
turn when you get a current going it's
an electric field which pulls all the
atoms going this way really quickly but
if you've got the temperature everything
sloshing around electrons will be
battered off and you won't get the same
kind of buildup of current so the first
time we did it this was jostling around
a lot so the electrons tried to get
through they were being scattered off
and so the actual current going through
it was not very much and so I only went
a little way we cool it down with a
liquid nitrogen it gets nice and cold
it's only moving a tiny bit it's only
moving a tiny bit so it's the electrons
try and go through less of them are
scattered because there's less
vibrations in the crystal less of them
are scattered more electrons shoot
through the more electrons shooting
through the further it flies
you